michel bergeron je crois qu'on peut lui
parler michel bergeron bonsoir je très
content vous soyez là pour se voir avant
c'est c'est une immense perte on mesure
là ça fait quoi depuis 8h ce matin qu'on
voit les réactions on mesure à quel
point il faisait partie du tissu de
notre imaginaire dans notre vie monsieur
lafleur
micro et un incroyable
j'ai fait partie de vingt dix le baby et
smart et lorsque je suis une conférence
ce matin qu'un jour sur le téléphone ce
matin en faisant
une nouvelle attaque prend je savais
médiatement je savais pas ce qu'il se
faisait des émois démons qui était qui
était malade qui
avait quitté
le lit sur des taux long de la journée
l'entendent à des gens parce que guy
foissy de ma vie
ottawa québec avec moi
tg il ya quelques rais quelques produits
qu'il dit glisse-t-elle est parfait
parfait il y
dix 10 était c'était tellement une
personne agréable à côtoyer pour
seulement athlètes leur mort me suis-je
à l'esprit avec guy même à new york des
fois il m'appelait pizza on devra les
faits je dis pas que je ne veux pas y
aller guy moi j'ai 20 matchs à
surveiller les allèles jugo harris
ponies paraissent parfois
nuisit guide nommé senior ghz qui me
réjouit télex à prendre exemple les
systèmes de joly ex les eaux il ya
toujours joué lui pas restée par passion
total 1 lui permettent et réseaux sont
alain lui parce que lui il y est c'est
un avant avant d'être talentueux c'est
un travail un d entre eux master était
toujours maximum pour ce que guy lafleur
a été l'idole de ses coéquipiers dans
les grandes années passées en plus
d'être le meilleur vatry c'est le plus
travaillé un temps c'est l'exemple ça
c'est pour les crochets merveilleux le
coach à saint-louis disais tout à
l'heure quand ils perdaient raconter une
anecdote qu'on lui avait raconté cahier
marqua pas la veille il faisait venir le
gardien substitut landry il a à 7 200
ont d'elle parce que qu'est-ce qui se
passe il était un travailleur acharné
ces projets du talent qui tombe du ciel
non absolument - roger écoute mais avec
les riders qui étayent avait fait elles
sont tout autant de retraite des revenus
bon avec moi new york puis il voulait et
voulait s'améliore de gizeh les mandats
des usa guy teytaud titre la fraction
second qui différencie le support des
spurs a hobo joie mêlée ils avaient
perdu tout autant de retraite non il n
en asie des faillites est convaincu
jouer
à michel parce que c'est quand même une
histoire incroyable il prend sa retraite
trop tôt dans sa tête est déçu et comme
déboussolé pendant quelques années puis
l'oeil monde et c'est vous qui lui avez
donné cette chance de rejouer dans la
ligue nationale mais ce n'est pas juste
un service que vous rendez il était
capable encore n'a absolument pour moi
je veux coacher kong et qui jouent aux
canadiens chaque les nausées ou saluer
baie-saint-paul la grande amitié mais
lorsqu'il nous a téléphoné à new york
après préparer mon camp d'entraînement
et leurs soins téléphone de guy sont à
son âge à son habitat et tremblay le
sont tous les deux franchement t'as peur
pour réparer quelque chose salut c'est
fois horreur s'allume shell je guide
faire un retour au jeu ja oui
mais oui mais oui au sérieux de ces
années un ami m'avait dit auparavant qui
avait vu guy jouer avec les anciens
léotard mary keller c'est sérieux mais
les copains je peux pas prendre
additions volet mon boss ratliff
exposito à niort du consort disons oui
je revenais big picture l'aimait
beaucoup qui accueillit fallait venir à
new york j'ai fait venir à new york en
avion c'est moi qui vais le chercher à
l'aéroport
plier à des légers doit arriver à
l'aéroport j'ai baigné beau visage en
forme comme guy lafleur guy lafleur il
s'entraînait paumé sais c'est un don de
dieu qu'il est leur aide au dessus ils
étaient tous les enfants donc je suis un
terrien baye dame au chapeau
aux gars de la new york rencontre et
phil schiller on parle blanc bye bye
fait que je fais lui dit on t'invite
aucun entraînement mais pas de contrat
il faut que je mérite une place parce
qu'ils coûtent trois ans de retraite
mais écoute une paresse et curieux ou
non la vente et on s'envoie
l'entraînement at war bien clair sur sa
mort est en beau fusil contre moi parce
qu'on a on avait fait le camp
d'entraînement
l'avènement des permissions rogers donc
il savoir lui des journalistes du camp
d'entraînement était de se ranger aux
rivières pouvoir guy marcel junkie joie
pour moi et l'équipe b premier
entraînement la côte d'ivoire est
rappelé à pleine capacité
bye bye bye tony granato porte la patte
folle à rodez hays guy encore deux
voyages furent gauvin bref
bacs le 1er but qu'un entraînement on
craque le premier but du canadien
bravo michel bergeron en 35 ans qu'est
ce qui fait que c'est fort aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui fait que tant connecter
avec les gens au québec
sa façon de vivre guy lafleur jamais
refusé de donner un autographe mais
jamais seul est refusé de saluer un
partisan je racontais des histoires
jusqu'à mais ma tête de ce que j'ai vu
de guy sait faire collaborer
sur son étoile mais enfin prophétie
s'est construit léger de réussite et là
j'ai souvent un mot qu'on galvaude
demande un mot qu'on lancera au travail
pour guy lafleur lui c'était droit comme
michel bergeron merci beaucoup de nous
avoir parlé bonne fin de soirée mais
c'est apprécié